والله الهجوم ايام احيانا مصالح سياسيه في
الدراجه الاولى
ويعني وشعور
ان القرارات اوبك بلس او الاوبك في صالح
هذه الدول او تلك هذه السبب الرئيسي في
الهجوم اما ما مساله المصلحه العامه لا
المملكه فهي ثابته واستقرار البترول واحد
من ضمنها واستقرار البترول وهدف من
الاستقرار البترول موجود قبل الابك وقبل
حتى
لما كانت تدير السوق نوعا ما يسمى
بالاخوات السبع كانت تسعى الى استقرار
السوق وتجتمع سنويا
شركات بتروليه في العالم انا
داركش بترول اليوم بيغيروا اسمها وشال
واكسب
قبل الاخوات السابع كان يوجد ما يسمى
تكساس في الرود كوميشن اللي هي مصلحه
الطرق الحديديه في تكساس في ذلك الوقت
كانت امريكا هي البلد الرئيسيه في الانتاج
وشركات البترول الامريكيه هي الرئيسيه
وكان الانتاج ياتي من ولايه تكساس من قبل
عده
شركات ولا تريد تلك الشركات اغراق السوق
ولذلك تريد ان
توازن السوق وتحافظ على توازننا من خلال
تقرير كميات الانتاج
والسياب الانتاج لماذا ذلك الوقت كان
البترول ينقل عن طريق سكك الحديد
ولهذا السبب كان كان الاستقرار
قبل ذلك جميع من بداوا في الانتاج هدفهم
الاستقرار لماذا تقول الاستقرار لان ليس
مصلحه ذاتيه ولكن
البترول
يحتاج الى استثمار بعيد المدى
واموال طائله
لا تستطيع ان تترك السوق بدون توازن والا
انهارت السوق توقفت الاستثمارات
الاسعار بشكل نهائي
بدايه البترول وسلعه تجاريه وهامه
وبدات السيارات
وغيرها استقرار السوق